hot breath how are you how are you able
to i feel like i've been doing comedy 10
years now and like i'm getting better at
bouncing back
from bombs but i mean you know they
still yeah they still suck
like how have you how have you been able
to kind of alleviate the
repercussions of a bomb and kind of make
it less
like daunting
i don't know man i think another set is
the only cure
yeah it's the only cure for a ball yeah
it's the only thing that can pull you
out is like a good set because then
you're like okay so i
don't so those people were wrong because
that's what you walk away from you're
like
was i wrong am i wrong to be in this
and then and then you and then you have
a good set and you're like oh no no
never mind
they were wrong [__] them these guys are
right this audience gets
it those other [__] adults didn't
understand what i was saying
yeah so it's there is no way and i think
honestly
it is uh bombing is the soreness
in comedic exercise it's like if if you
if if you're really sore then you need
to work out more
you need to be up there more and it's
like there it's always gonna there's
gonna be a soreness with it because
you're like
man i've had mornings where i've woken
up and i've been like
god damn it that last show like i'll do
three shows at the stand
in the first two i'll be like looks like
i found what i was born on this earth to
do
and then the third show would be like
hey uh should i
uh kill myself by eating my own [__]
because
that last crowd couldn't have cared less
well it's good we're not alone in that
feeling nah man bomb but it's also a
necessity
it's like uh you know it's just a it's a
part of the process
i'm gonna dude coming back i'm in st
louis june 25th through the 27th
that first show there are going to be
some misses
there are going to be some i don't it
might not even be the first show it
might be like
friday late show where i'm like what the
[__] am i doing on stage
you